okay we're going to be working with
finding a sinusoidal equation
given the maximum and the minimum and
how do we do that well you're already
familiar with graphing sine and cosine
so this is a little bit more challenging
because we're having to work backwards
to find the equation
i'm going to show you how to work with
these formulas as well as like a more
intuitive way of working with it
visually by graphing it so let's dive
into this um
video here the first thing is let's
graph
the max and the min so the max is at
negative 1 2
the minimum is at 1 negative 4 and so if
i was to draw
a sketch it would look something like
that now remember the sine and cosine
graph they keep going in both directions
forever and ever but what i want to
point out to you is when you go from the
maximum to the minimum
right maximum to the minimum notice that
this is
actually half of one period
so we can see from negative one to
positive one that's a distance of
two but the period would actually be
double it actually would be four
okay now the formula that we use to find
the b
value is this guy here period equals two
pi divided by b
so let's go ahead and do that to figure
out what b is so if the period is 4
4 is like 4 over 1 we can cross multiply
so
4b equals 2 pi
divide both sides by 4 and you can see
that b equals 2 pi over 4 which is like
pi
over 2 if we reduce okay so now we have
our b value
the next thing i like to do is i like to
find this midline
the midline is what kind of divides the
graph in half half the graph is above
half the graph is below normally that
midline falls right on the x-axis
but in this case let's see we're here at
negative 4
positive 2 that's the distance of 6. so
halfway would be
3 up or 3 down so that's going to put us
right here
and that's going to be our our new
midline but you can see that midline
instead of being at the x-axis
has actually shifted down 1 so that
means that our k value is equal to
negative 1.
now you can also use this formula max
plus min divided by two
so that'd be two plus negative four is
negative two divided by two is negative
one
so same answer now for the amplitude the
amplitude is like how high these waves
are
but that's from the perspective of the
midline like if you're on a beach you're
measuring how high the waves are it's
not like you're on a surfboard
you know and you're trying to measure
like from here down to here
so what you want to do is you can find
from that midline we're going up
one two three or going down one two
three so we know our amplitude
is equal to three but to use the formula
we take 2 minus negative 4 which is like
2
plus 4 which is 6 divided by 2 is 3 the
absolute value is always positive so you
get the same answer amplitude of 3.
now the next thing i like to do is do
the horizontal shift the phase shift
that's our h value in these equations
here
i like to start with the cosine graph
because cosine starts right at the
maximum here right on the y-axis
and it goes down to the minimum back up
to the maximum so here this
if we're doing a cosine graph you can
see normally the cosine would start here
it's shifting
left 1. so we're going to say that h is
equal to
negative 1 okay so let's put this all
together now
with the cosine graph we have y is equal
to
amplitude of 3 cosine
the b value is pi over 2 is shifting
left one so it's going to be x minus
negative one which is like x plus one
remember the one that's grouped with the
x here this has the opposite effect plus
one's going
left one if it was minus one it would go
right one and then we said that the
k value was down one so it shifted down
one
that's our new midline so this is our
cosine graph but you're probably saying
you know mario
how about the sine graph well the other
important thing that i want you to
realize is that from the max to the min
that we said that was half of a period
right but the difference between the
cosine graph and the sine graph is
they're out of phase by a quarter of a
period
see like how cosine starts right here if
you were to continue that graph to the
left
see now you can see this looks like a
sine graph right
so this is really like see if you were
to take this sine graph right here and
shift it left by a quarter of a period
it would end up see this point would be
right here and that would be a cosine
graph
so they're out of phase by a quarter of
a period in this case since the period
was
four a quarter of four is going to be
one so they're just out of
phase by one so what we would do now is
we would have to shift it to the
left one but when you do that left one
means you're actually going to be
adding one because this has the opposite
effect so now we can write our sine
graph
three sine pi over 2 x
plus 2 minus 1 and that's going to be
your sine graph
now again you can also add multiple
periods you could say if i add 4 here x
plus 6 or if you subtract 4
x minus 2 that would also be an equation
of the graph here and you've got it so
if you want to see another example i'll
put a link to the video that i did
another example with the same concept
right there
i'll see you over in that video